according to the wall street journal in
their poll a vast majority of you the
american people disagree with that
statement 83 percent now describe our
economy rightly so as poor not good at
all here with reaction is the host of
the monica crowley podcast monica
crowley along with former massachusetts
senator scott brown
monica just the opposite is true isn't
it
that's exactly right sean i mean there's
spin and every white house puts a gloss
on reality when it comes to the politics
involved and and the need to to put a
certain spin on things but then there is
outrageous blatant lying which is
exactly what this white house is doing
and what they have done literally since
day one particularly on the economy you
cannot put lipstick on a pig and then
convince the american people that it's
something other than a pig wearing
lipstick the american people are living
this catastrophic economy every single
day sean they are being squeezed between
skyrocketing inflation record high gas
prices and a drop in real wages they are
struggling every day to make ends meet
and yet the democrats don't care what
you saw from senator stabenow today sean
that kind of callous disregard that
cavalier attitude about high gas prices
and well i'm just in my electric car
this is like a modern version of marie
antoinette instead of let them eat cake
let them buy a tesla and all of this
indicates that it is all intentional
rather than trying to work to alleviate
american suffering here because they
could change tomorrow if they wanted to
particularly on energy policy but they
won't so what that tells you is this is
all intentional as part of the
fundamental transformation of the nation
and that's a good point that's the
climate alarmist cult aspect that i talk
about and they're all indoctrinated into
it uh scott brown uh americans are
reminded every single day that what
they're hearing from the white house is
an outright lie every time they go to
fill up the gas tank every store they go
to they're paying a fortune more than
they were paying even a year ago
so all all of the
you know bs that they're trying to
peddle and the narrative they're selling
is not going to fly
well it's not flying sean as you know i
just drove in i paid 505 that's just for
the cheapest gas i could find on the way
into manchester in new hampshire's
diesel prices are the highest they've
ever been and six seven eight days in a
row as you know it's it's going up up up
up we were energy independent less than
two years ago the administration made it
crystal clear as you referenced that
they were going to do away with fossil
fuels and crush the coal and oil
industries which they're doing they're
doing everything in their power to do so
they are trying to really reshape the
economy to go into a green economy and
he's not going to do anything because he
wants that green vote all the you know
the aocs and all the others and
respectfully to senator stabenow listen
she's a multi-millionaire she probably
paid cash the average citizen can't do
that you can't find a cheap hybrid car
because by then they're already you know
not reliable as you know and and we can
do better we we shouldn't be having to
go to venezuela and actually saudi
arabia on our knees begging for oil this
is america and the va and the president
and the vice president the
administration yelling especially
inflation the border i mean we could go
on and on we got to get our act together
here so uh you know i'm hopeful they
they wake up somehow and it's going to
be in the next election cycle
i hope so that's coming soon the next
two election cycles actually matter the
most monica thank you that's right and
scott brown always good to see you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else